because at that time it's like what do
you do out there in Nebraska for fun he
has mannequins of black people that he
hits with the bull whips there's no
pinball arcades out there dude that what
was it
there's just black kids coming up and
they're like that guy definitely does
all that
[Music]
so there's a man
who in 1967 he murdered his parents
right he's a he's a United States
citizen he murders his parents as a
teenager
by shooting them then he escapes from
prison
flees to Australia and lives a
completely separate Life as a successful
businessman wow he's like a dad talk
about turning his life around right
um and his family only just learned of
his past after he died maybe his parents
they didn't learn about his Escape what
do you mean like his his friend like his
oh like his kids and [__] Alias New Life
new identity wow hey at that point let
him have it yeah you think that yeah if
you made it that far he's dead already
yeah [__] it man you kind of deserve it
yeah he didn't kill anybody else after
that right yeah it wasn't like he was
probably doing a string of murder and I
mean like soldiers go out to war kill
people come back yeah they're all good
the motive it depends on the motive this
is him when he was arrested for
murdering his parents big time oh yeah
they used to beat the [__] out of him
for sure look at that maybe his parents
remain yeah they used to be the [__]
remember the remember that they looked
like the spanking title yeah oh no I
mean that Dad right there yeah he looks
like an alcoholic abuser oh people
that's a Jim Crow Polo team
got to see Jim
yeah cornfields
yeah because at that time it's like what
do you do out there in Nebraska for fun
he has mannequins of black people that
he hits with the bull whip there's no
pinball arcades out there dude that what
was it or whatever they're just black
kids coming up and they're like that guy
definitely does all that so let's say
that that happened to you like an
[__] let's say that guy was in your
family yeah that's like my dad gets out
of prison the prison doesn't notify the
family like hey he's out he might come
get you oh no no no so no no no no no he
murders his parents and goes to prison
after so so get this he gives his time
September 27 1958 he gets a rifle from
his pants run and he confronts his mom
and she's like what are you gonna do
shoot me and he's like yeah and he shot
her he fired six trigger pulls and
[__] blew her whole [__] chest
cavity on her tits falling around
and he walked over he had he actually
was holding groceries right he comes in
a couple minutes later and then
um the dad like sees the gun and he just
[__] immediately drops the groceries
and [__] they have a tussle and then
the dad was like on top the kid pulled
the sugar and the dad had to look in his
eyes like but then the kid had to look
at his eyes too so we didn't know who
who
like in the movie yeah you just hear a
shot but then the dad slumped over so
then we knew the kids oh my God wait how
old was he when he did uh when it did
when he did the murder he was the 13
years old uh he's a new person I feel
like any time you you commit crime under
like 20. yeah you're a different human
being
how long was he in the prison until he
escaped uh not long he pretty much
escaped like right away back in those
days you could do that I guess it's
easier yeah they didn't have barbed wire
on the fence wait wait wait wait time
out why'd they chase his ass
you know they would have had hounds on
black people yeah I know I keep bringing
this all back this whole episode I think
in the 50s just everyone was white there
I think maybe more in Nebraska right
maybe not yet I don't know another hot
spot for black folks dude
nobody wants to go to Nebraska
they were still in Baldwin Hills
until you brought it up I forgot it was
a state dude I forgot it was a good
place
you forgot about Nebraska yeah they're
good at not attracting guys like us to
go there they're low-key Nebraska solo
key yeah they're like oh we're good
we're good what would you do in Nebraska
play football what oh yeah all you do is
you you go outside you put your hands on
your hips you go that's a mighty fine
Town it is if you go back that's all you
do then their college have a really good
football team Nebraska yeah the Corn
Huskers so that's where all the black
people are they're on the football yeah
they're on the football team but not in
the 50s yeah so you escaped yeah dates
from prison after so he's in prison for
a time right like eight year stretch
yeah whoa he takes
um these rubber masks that they found in
the prison yard and razor blades and
he's actually manages to file off one of
the bars on his window whoa the classic
like you know very Classic this is the
blueprint he started it he took the
rubber mask and made it look like his
head's on the pillow and he crawled out
and he crawled out of the Winds Alcatraz
that's how they escaped nothing wow yeah
similar and then so he got out and then
somehow he how to get to Australia
somehow yeah that's pretty crazy yeah
what the heck maybe on a cargo ship he
managed to obtain a phony identity
papers he assumed the name of John Damon
and became a Salesman wow and he he kept
on relocating so he moved to Cincinnati
and then he moved to to Miami and then
um it was a tight movie yeah this
movie's yeah badass his family ended up
moving to New Zealand or him and his
family end up moving to New Zealand also
he made an new family in America oh we
got in the states yeah he got a wife
right they ended up having marriage
troubles he divorces her he gets with
his second wife they decide to move to
New England right and she was she was a
New Zealand because she was a foreign
exchange student wow and then they had a
son and daughter and then they moved to
New Zealand in 92. so she's originally
from New Zealand I don't it doesn't say
it just says she was a foreign exchange
student and then they settled in
Australia about 97 and he earned a
respectable living He spared no expense
for his kids and their educations and he
was almost overly supportive of what one
of his kids said he was so he didn't
blow his second chance basically yeah
apparently not he learned a lot in
prison
now what was his sentence supposed to be
my life it doesn't say if you blow both
of your parents murder yeah double
murder
it says that he pled guilty and sent a
letter of apology to his neighbor so he
was like sorry for the noise
send an apology to the neighbors sorry
for the titties
we were shooting too yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know what's funny that the
thought that he did all this effort to
get away but he could have just lived
next to the jail they weren't looking
for him at all I know right yeah like
yeah how yeah how strong of a [__]
search the date it's like Catch Me If
You Can with no one chasing you yeah
seriously because yeah I guess I had to
relocate a couple times so he's
obviously being careful about it damn
what a smart kid back then it was
probably easy to just like when you're
in a different country you're in a
different country he's better than
career criminals after like one in
practice Yeah that's pre-dnation and he
did juvenile crime so like like if you
would have did that now yeah he would
have he would have got he'd have to like
be a hacker to get away now yeah yeah
because now you're in the system yeah
like when someone's in trouble like with
the with flying flightless no fly list
back then you could pay for a ticket
cash that's true at the airport that's
right there was no TSA and then you just
go do you remember back in the day like
the good old days we were able to go up
to the actual place where they were uh
deplaning you could say bye at the
tunnel thingy oh yeah yeah oh yeah and
we used to be able to pick up people at
the gate yeah at their gate that's true
I remember that [__] dude there was no
[__] like TSA thing that no giant
buffer yeah then yeah you can walk in
you can eat together at the restaurants
there yeah they leave you actually make
your flight on time dude
yeah I remember being a little kid and
then like picking up people at the
airport with my family like they would
just park in that middle parking
structure yeah and go walk across the
street and I remember specifically
because I was so hyped that day that I
ran across during
um I ran across traffic to see somebody
and then my mom was like holy [__] and
all these cars were stopping and this
bus stopped in front of me and then my
impulsive ass was like what and then
there's this big ass bus there and I
looked over I was like oh [__] and then
I guess a lot of cars were honking and
like yeah yeah you could even stewardess
ass and she would just go Mr jutsukawa
you crazy boy
my first sweet cheeks
yo my first time flying was a year after
9 11. whoa no way how'd I feel yeah
that's that white people [__] it was it
was a little weird because I mean yeah I
mean I never first I've never flown so I
didn't know what it was like and then
also like knowing uh just from Arizona
to Vegas oh okay yeah and and so like I
don't know it was kind of scary I wish I
knew it was I wish I was sitting next to
you and I knew that and I was like
[__] away
you're just sitting there like [__]
looking down the aisle just [__]
ready to [__] pop off you know what
sex is that that time of flying it
really did suck for anybody that was uh
yeah it was frightening if you were Arab
or you had an Arab sounding name yeah I
had friends that that changed their name
that year yeah really oh so much [__]
was popping off Nadeem always gets uh
randomly searched and randomly
questioned at the gym
please step through this sir please
so it must feel like a night and day
difference today right I am for sure but
like still it's I mean that was for my
first experience tensions were high yeah
it was like I think it was like 15 a lot
of cheap flights that year a lot of
cheap flights yeah no one's going
anywhere kind of on this story's topic
um Hannah's great grandfather had a
second family here in America what yeah
because he was like uh he was like he
worked on on the ships or something
because uh in Wales it was like a big
Port so they would go back and forth
America all these places and so he he
had like two families it must be so hard
when they did like a DNA test and all
these other things they would like they
found out like oh [__] there's like
American relatives wow apparently he was
a really cool great grandfather like to
the family here in America but then he
was he had a favorite yeah does Hannah
want to like connect with us he's like
interesting I think some of their
relatives reached out and then some of
them didn't I guess like the history
that they were told oh because he was a
pleasant dude here but over there in the
UK he was a [__] he was a mean guy he
was a pretty yeah brutal dude you think
it was the weather yeah like there's a
story about all the girls the food the
food and the weather he was like
all the grandparents the the the kids of
the great grandpa right they conspired
to [__] kill him whoa so they all
they all got weapons they were getting
he was that bad
and when he was coming downstairs they
were just gonna Ambush his ass and just
[__] beat him to death and then like
what are you nodding like you've been
there so true it sounds like this story
yeah yeah yeah I think back in the day
everyone just want to kill their parents
right it is kind of similar but like it
but like honestly like that that was
such a common thing back in the day for
like dudes to have like multiple [__]
families it was so [__] common yeah I
wonder if that was a flex too did you
tell your friends it probably was and it
was just you just have one family yeah
yeah
but also like I feel like people didn't
just hook up like you had to if you
wanted to bone somebody like you had to
go and get married and like that's why
Vegas had that shotgun wedding [__]
because I think I don't care yeah
because he wanted a bone so you just got
married so because we were probably
following that Christian value of like
no sex till marriage yeah damn yeah I
don't think I could do that's too many
[__] people no sex until Elvis
marries us yeah no yeah it's a lot of
work man that's a lot of [__] work
why
[Music]